[Musique]
tous ceux qui s'intéressent au cinéma ne
serait désormais imaginer qu'à mme
samson palais des festivals à plus forte
raison lorsque hazard savamment calculé
nous y retrouver jean seberg la plus
ravissante jeune comédienne que
l'amérique est depuis longtemps offert à
la france en cette saison elle peut
tranquillement se promener sur la
croisette
bien à l'abri de la curiosité dont elle
serait l'objet à toute autre époque de
l'année c'est le tournage d'un film
importantes productions américaines qui
attire et jean seberg sur la côte d'azur
son titre moment tout moment d'une
minute à l'autre réalisateur un vieux
routier d'hollywood
mervyn leroy comment pouvez vous être
quelqu'un d'autre
quelques minutes seulement par jour
alors que tout le reste du temps vous
êtes là très considéré mi6 berg entouré
et chouchouté par toute l'équipe du film
puisque vous en êtes la vedette comme
celle laissée choque ce n'est pas si
difficile parce que jeune femme d'un
milieu qui pouvaient plus ou moins
d'être un ami à une jeune américaine
mariée un docteur
vivant sur la côte d'azur est autrement
dans un film comme neuf qui va sortir je
préférais où je jouais à une jeune femme
schizophrène d'infoman lesbiennes tout
ce qu'on veut c'était beaucoup plus
difficile c'est beaucoup plus difficile
de se concentrer parce que comme vous
voyez il ya toujours de l'agitation
autour donc pour vous il est plus facile
de coller un rôle et un personnage dans
un film avec une équipe réduite comme un
signe de godard par exemple ah oui c'est
c'est tout de même je pense l'idéal
vraiment améliorée de moi que les gens
dont c'est le métier de connaître tout
ce qui se passe dans le cinéma arrive
ici comme c'est arrivé et ils n'ont
jamais entendu parler de tout faux et il
ne sait pas ce que belmont doit être une
immense dette en europe et est que tout
est tellement fermé que cellulaire
l'impression réellement d'être sur une
autre planète et je n'aime pas ça
[Musique]
vous donnez l'impression d'avoir acquis
beaucoup d'assurance et de n'agir
qu'après mûre réflexion
ah oui oui aussi c'est votre côté
américain les américaines sur les femmes
de tête qui savent bien je ne sais pas
je crois pas que je suis une femme de
tête du tout mais ici si je garde cette
façade
tant mieux mais je dis bien il avait
fait sa valeur puisque c'est une cause
mais une façade c'est ce que montre pour
ne pas montrer scolaire également moi
j'ai plutôt le contraire je crois c'est
à dire c'est à dire très impulsif un peu
trop enfantin et nerveuse donc une sorte
de masque que vous portez un masque
souriant mais hamas que tout de même
levé
oui oui mais ça n'a pas changé avec les
comédiens nous portons tous les masses
tout le temps vous ne voyez jamais un
comédien du thiou plus cela scène que
vous le voyez jouer dans un restaurant
quand vous disiez avec lui bien que au
cinéma n'y ait ni masque ni cothurnes
comme sur l'asean à moi ça me prend une
heure tous les matins à 6 voies mais
demande masque alors c'est tout vous
évoluez dans le milieu du cinéma dans un
univers factice univers assez faut
finalement la vie ce n'est pas le cinéma
tout de même
non il ne l'est pas pour moi mais j'ai
beaucoup de chance parce que j'ai de la
chance même d'être exposé je pense à
l'europe d'être exposé à d'autres idées
de ne pas avoir traîné
sous les palmiers en californie en
attendant dévale petite foule par ci par
là j'ai eu beaucoup de chance dans la
vie en général et j'ai de la chance même
à rencontrer nos mairies et tout cela a
fait que pour moi ce n'est pas tout je
crois que c'est la tragédie du cinéma
souvent c'est pourquoi ça termine si mal
ça devient tout et on est en et mangez
pas ça
finalement vous ne voulez pas vous
laisser dévorer
[Musique]